in the premiere you go off on Michael
for a ringtone
you were also passing okay so do you
blame it on the PMS or do you say now
looking back like no he deserved that
now it's our that because um we actually
were I was actually married Mr Riddick
you know what all and then it took one
thing to make me just to feel the way I
was really feel and you know ii mean
like the rings on which I am willing
about the reason actually it was about
how he acted with the ring come closer
what was that you know and bye
nothing nothing if it was nothing then
you know why did you just say ringtone
for my mechanic why did you act so
suspicious then you know being the path
to Michael their culture is different
and they talk different than us and I've
learned that you know but I still have
to remind myself that I've heard their
culture in your mind and learn to learn
you know for me I'm just an you better
like you you know good and well you
should've said you know the Rings song
was my mechanic you made me think that
yeah do you want me to hear it you know
it was far away home rest you know but I
was already mad at him you know what
were you already mad about I can't come
out during the show okay
do you still have trust issues when it
comes to Michael you know I think not I
don't know I don't think I have here my
views in here enough just being a
typical I'm gonna just being a man I
mean you know I mean I'm a woman I
understand maybe I never knew I was
old-fashioned but maybe an old-fashioned
I think that you know seeing what's been
played out there on people and being
around you know I'm very hip you know I
don't give him a break you know I mean
I'll give him a break when he's doing
way oh and because I'm not a cheater I'm
not a you know we could be fighting for
long and I still won't go out do it or
not supposed to do you know I'll still
remember that I love him and I don't
want to be suspected in that manner so
you know
and the question was trust I trust them
you know and has their areas in some
areas I just wanna make sure he doesn't
think that being over there you can
sneak you know and it would be harm
that's what he's sneaking but still I
don't like that you know just tell me
what you're gonna do I can get mad if
I'm you know the man is quick or if you
say listen I'm going there and that's it
you get mad get mad
what's your message to those people who
say the way you react to him sometimes
just it's out of question
well you know I tell them this you know
I don't mind their opinions I don't get
mad at their opinions I don't get better
what they say you can it's at the end of
the day I have to leave this life with
Michael not them and they're always
looking inside the house you know nobody
tells it all you know what I mean
there's going to be some kind of privacy
between you and your man you and your
woman but I just say I'm inviting them
to see our journey I'm not inviting you
to tell me how to live my job so would
that be instead you can have all the
opinions you can go on my page and I let
you again I I don't get mad you I don't
care
listen you got a ride but the end the
day Angela's gonna do what she wants to
do and I've let the world into our life
and I'm trying to help other people not
to be used by anybody from any country
and you know if I am so bad that people
think um they obviously don't know my
cozily not even for a green card but you
know sometimes just being a foreigner
even maybe Micronesia there's always
people like it's a crank or you know no
so we've been American maybe five for
section percent might think that but
when I get my senses back I know I
really put him on holiday now we won't
really know now we wait because you know
I've always thought that past
relationships oh this is gonna work and
then you know you see where a man I'm
with Michael so all I can kill em is to
keep marching in it's all right but I
want you to like get me here and we'll
see when you have those moments where
you kind of think like maybe he is
scamming me or you had those doubts here
and there what what makes you come back
to the realization and no he's he's
furrow
he's really an operator I mean I
literally pray on it
and I think I know my heart you know I
just pray and you know I'll think about
that during that whole night you think
but how far we've come in no you know
reality I have four six buttons to the
limit and how couldn't they load me to
go through what he's gone through with
the enemy
like it ain't all about Michael bleep
and I know something that I do is really
chaotic but that's me if I you know any
woman has been hurt in the past you know
and not this point I'm you know my age
we're gonna be on guard and maybe I'm
too much but at the end the day Michael
can tell you then there's nothing I
wouldn't give him a place like look at
me I'm trying to funny
are you still actively trying to get
pregnant absolutely believe it or not um
it's only fair you know I do everything
possible because you've never asked me
for much and you know it's gonna be a
lot of money maybe it's gonna be this
method if that means Tim his mom had
because I really love his mom died and
he just deserves one one way or another
but there will not be no no releasing
him to other women
right cuz that is I mean we've seen some
other people talk about that option
that's something that is off limits for
you yeah I know that's know if I do
everything possible I can in me Michael
but then they don't mean that he'll come
there will be no room for the women I
don't like to eat off my plate
okay oh yeah great right okay
[Music]